[Musique]
voir les enfants
que se passe-t-il nounours pas trop mon
petit doigt violent me dire qu'il faut
que je défende mettre de l'ordre chez
mes petits amis tu crois oui on a besoin
de moi pas je vais faire la grosse voix
au
bond le gel
pop pop a promis aux
petites poupées tu n'es pas sage tu dois
certains toits les halles ont fait voir
le bout de ton nez l'avait mois se
trémousse tout arbouille et de confiture
sans alors tu es une poupe est un
prêcheur on voit tap le cap russe au que
ce que j'entends
bébé caprice d'ici au 11
il est propre maintenant notre but de
caprice o o
ce n'est pas trop tard
caprice et sage l affaire de d'où
venaient
pauvres de nous
il est si drôle quand il fait sa grosse
voix
tu vois m'annonce moi je suis pas un
caprice tu l'as ma figure mais dans mes
mains
chers petits
ne réveillez pas ma beauty l d'eau
d'où tout cas pris
[Musique]
ce que vous êtes sages ce soir oui
pour me faire plaisir
non nous sommes sages car nous voulons
aller en vacances j'ai comme chou dans
sa roulotte et on jouera avec son cheval
dada vous êtes des petits malins et on
lui apprendra à compter à cornillon
c'est une excellente idée là j'éteins la
lumière
bonne nuit les petits
bernanos
on lui apprendra comptait même jusqu'à
10 e
2,3 seuls 4 5 6 7 8 9 7 8 9 et 10
bonita prenait lé connu nicolas
[Musique]
bravo les enfants vous savez très bien
compter moi aussi pas trop je compterai
bien un 2 5 n'ont nounours 1 2 et 3 en
route que je suis juste heureux au
2/3 aux routes pas trop d'années les
enfants 4 5 cette fête de bourrins vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]